hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great Sunday now I wouldn't want you
to get the impression that rashidun is
matino is deadly only with the white
pieces so this next game I prepared for
you
Rashid is playing with the black pieces
he's playing against love babaeski
a very strong grandmaster and he was a
world championship contender I mean he
played in the candidates tournament four
times and he was a very well respected
chess author and an opening theorist and
well he was considered to be one of the
strongest players since 1960s and 1980s
and well let's see how this game goes
and why they call Nativity no no reverse
gear Rashid
so Paul guess he is white and he plays
d4 we have Knight f6 management in of c4
d6 night c3 and now II five this is the
old engine detail it descends and well
white isn't interested in capturing on
e5 and trading Queens so he plays efore
where she plays he captures on d4 Queen
captures on d4 and now Knight to c6 with
the tempo on the Queen we have point to
D to G 6 by Rashid b3 Bishop to g7
Bishop to b2 Rashid castles Bishop to d3
and our he plays Knight to g4 he plunges
the night into the attack we have an ID
g - e - and rashid plays Queen to h4
threatening to capture on f2 so we have
night - g3 and now Rashid plays Knight
gt5 sort of to the caress this Bishop
and d3 if the Queen ever moves
we have castles and where she plays f5
so we have F 3 and then our she plays
Bishop to h6 attacking the Queen and d2
so poganski plays Queen to d1 and now
where she goes f4 going forward we have
na g - e - and no reverse gear she goes
g5 so we have Knight to d5 and now again
Rasheed goes forward he plays g4 we have
g3 by poganski F captures and g3 H
captures and
III and now Queen to h2 and here
poganski plays f4 to block this Bishop
and to kick this night of the strongly v
square and this is the where Rashid
plays Bishop to e6 offers the entire
night and this isn't some kind of a move
that Rashid played just to get into
bogus his head this is well actually the
strongest move recommended by the angel
so let's see what happens if the knight
is captured if then I just kept sure def
captures any five Rashid would play
different captures on d5 and after it
captures on d5 you would get a Bishop to
e3 check here we have rook to f2 and
Bishop captures on f2 and this is
checkmate so a very nice idea of
anonymity nove
so after Bishop to e6 pawn SK decided to
play Bishop to c2 and again you can
capture the night here because it was
the same idea
so Russia plays rook to f6 we have king
- f - Queen - H - check
poganski plays king - H King to e3 and
now Rashid captures Bishop captures on
d5 we have C captures on d5 and this is
a this is where well in this position
you really have to figure out what the
play was black and this is what Rashida
makes you do he makes you play real
chess he makes you play it over the
board and he makes you do it now
immediately well the clock is ticking he
plays nice to be four and what I feel
out here he allow the poganski to play a
rock h1 and to trap a niche between us
Queen so that's that's what the Pulaski
does he plays rook to h1 and now
Rasheed's queen is trapped but this is
the position Rashida wanted to achieve
and in this position rush it plays rook
captures on f4 and now look at this
position this is this is one crazy
position
it's a beautiful position but also a
crazy position so this roots can be
captured it can be captured with the
night and it can be captured with the g3
point so let's see what happens if
Esther's on f4 if not captures on f4
whatever she would play Knight captures
on c2 which check and as you can see
there is no square for the White King to
go to only move would be to capture the
night with the Queen and well Russia
would win for guess kiss queen
but another move after rook captures an
f4 well you could capture with the Jeep
on so if the G captures on f4 you would
get Bishop captures on f4 check you will
get King to d4 and now Queen to f2 check
you get King to c3 and now Queen to c5
this is checkmate vine is matino so
after rook captures on f4 rush it is
practically forcing Pulaski to capture
his queen so it's what Pulaski does he
plays rook captures on h2 and now net
matino plays rook f3 check and let's see
what Valdez key does he plays rook King
to d4 and well again we have a very
crazy position and probably in this
position you would be looking for that
one move that ends the game instantly
and well Rashid actually plays a slow
move he plays a quiet move that's
actually even more deadly he plays
Bishop to g7 and well this White King
isn't really going anywhere
I mean in this position you would
probably rather resigned and calculate
all the ideas where she has so pole
guess key plays a for just you know to
prevent some future b5 and also making
some room for the king if it comes to
that because poll guess you know that
his king is probably going for a very
long walk so we have c5 management in of
checking the White King we have D
captures and c6 b captures on c6 and now
Bishop to d3
sort of blocking the rope so the king
can go to C 3 but Rasheed of course does
not allow that he plays Knight captures
on d3 and now checking the White King
cuts off the c3 square by the bishop and
g7 so we have king to c4 by pole guess
key now Rafi plays d5 check EK % d5c
Kesterson d5 would check King to b5 we
look the BH check management in of King
to a5 Knight to c6 check and in this
position left photographs resigned
because well only movies came to a6 and
after that Bishop to b5 is a knight to
b5 is checkmate so yeah like I said I
didn't want you to get the impression
that synergy Moutinho was only deadly
with the white pieces so this is a
beautiful King walk and a beautiful
combination banishment he knows and she
really did take that King for a walk so
yeah and does the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here and thank
you all who contributed to my channel I
would like to thank you reason my recent
donors Vincent Gallo see Michael white
Richard I'll and John - bye thank you
all guys I really appreciate it and well
I just wanted to say for the end of this
video that I do know a lot about yes I
read a lot of books and anytime I can
read something about about yes I do read
it whether it's on some blog Twitter
Facebook or anywhere but when you
comment on my videos I really do learn a
lot and I really do get ideas for my
next video for example I was planning to
show this game between Paul gave skin is
matheno but someone actually also
suggested it in the comments so I was
really happy to show it and I will show
another game between Paul gasps skin is
matino in another video which is also
really really interesting so yeah that's
about it
and like I said I do hope you enjoyed it
and I'll see you soon